une autre vigile un autre hommage aux
215 enfants disparus que l'histoire
avait oublié jusqu'à tout récemment dans
sept premières nations de la
saskatchewan comme toutes les autres
pays la découverte de kamloops kabel de
douloureux souvenirs particulièrement
pour ceux qui ont survécu nous
pensionnat et de partout la même
question surgit
combien d'autres enfants sont morts dans
l'oubli la fédération des nations
autochtones souveraine de la
saskatchewan met la pression sur les
gouvernements étaient loin de s'estomper
l'ondé de choc accélère le rejet des
symboles coloniaux du passé ce matin la
statue de john mcdonald le premier
premier ministre canadien créateur des
pensionnats a été déboulonnée au centre
ville de charlottetown à
l'île-du-prince-édouard
[Musique]
car oui le conseil scolaire annonce que
deux écoles portant les noms d'hector
langevin et de l'évêque grand des deux
architectes des pensionnats sont
rapidement renommée ce que souhaite le
maire depuis longtemps et pour moi c'est
un peu tard mais ces tentes des kits et
la communauté et de faire ce changement
partout au pays l'heure est à la
réflexion à toronto wagons de métro
tramways autobus se sont arrêtés pendant
deux minutes
la plus grande ville du pays a pris une
pause pour rendre hommage aux 215
enfants disparus s'ils vivent encore
avec les traumatismes des pensionnats
bon nombre de canadiens en apprennent
l'existence depuis quelques jours le
mois national de l'histoire des
autochtones qui débute aujourd'hui
et justement consacré cette année aux
enfants disparus et aux survivants des
pensionnats le des chapitres les plus
sombres de l'histoire canadienne est
exposé au grand jour
impossible maintenant de l'ignorer ici
mathieu weill et radio canada elle même